. So it turns out that it's not just outsiders
realizing that Donald Trump's legal team,
of course, including Rudy Giuliani, are making
him look like an idiot.
We've now learned that Donald Trump's inner
circle has also been advising Donald Trump.
Hey, what Rudy is doing is completely embarrassing.
The Daily Beast reports that members of Trump's
inner circle have been coming to him and saying,
sir, that's my ad lib, sir.
He's making you look like an idiot.
Remember that just days prior, NBC reported
Trump was worried that his legal team consisted
of, quote, fools that are making him look
bad.
So it does appear that this is what Donald
Trump is being told, but it's not stopping
Trump.
Trump continues tweeting about these people.
He continues promoting these harebrained voter
fraud events.
They did one yesterday.
We covered a little bit of it live.
It was Rudy Giuliani and another Trump, Attorney
General Ellis, in a room in a hotel with some
Republican Arizona lawmakers bringing so-called
witness after witness to essentially say they
didn't like the way they were treated as polling
observers.
It was a bizarre dog and pony show, but Trump
keeps promoting it.
Yesterday, Trump tweeted Trump legal team
in Arizona and on OCN.
Now, big stuff.
Enjoy.
This is not because people aren't telling
Trump his legal team is making him look ridiculous.
Trump is being told that we now know, but
he continues to promote these events.
Now, there's a couple of possibilities.
One possibility is Trump believes that these
lawyers are making him look stupid, but he
doesn't care because it either keeps his name
in the news or it lets him fundraise half
of the money.
Remember half of the money fundraised for
these recounts and all this nonsense, half
the money goes to paying off his campaign
debt.
So maybe Trump thinks it's worth it.
Maybe Trump here, the people coming to him
and saying these lawyers are making you look
stupid and he doesn't believe it.
That's still a possibility that Trump just
doesn't believe that they're making him look
dumb.
But look at the list now.
Rudy Giuliani hosted that ridiculous press
conference at a landscaping parking lot in
Philadelphia weeks ago.
Then Rudy does another press briefing in the
basement of a building somewhere in D.C.
That was the one where Rudy's hair dye made
it look like he was bleeding out of both ears.
Then Rudy shows up at a hearing in Pennsylvania
with Republican state lawmakers and spends
hours making unfounded claim after claim about
the election.
But then Trump calls into that one.
So he couldn't have thought Trump, that is,
Trump couldn't have thought that one made
him look bad.
Right.
I mean, he participated in it after all.
And then yesterday, Trump also called into
the Arizona I don't even like calling it a
hearing PR event.
That Rudy Giuliani did, and meanwhile, there
are increasingly calls for Rudy Giuliani himself
to have his legal license revoked for continuing
to file these bogus legal challenges, all
of which are getting thrown out the real way
that Trump made himself look like an idiot
is hiring Rudy in the first place to represent
him in court.
And I've talked about this before.
There's a big difference between a TV lawyer
and a courtroom lawyer.
Rudy Giuliani for a while was Trump's TV lawyer,
meaning he went on TV and he advocated for
the president.
But he did it in a way that you wouldn't actually
do in a courtroom.
So on TV, Rudy says voter fraud and he says
they have all this evidence and proof of all
these different things in a courtroom.
Rudy is really not equipped to handle these
cases, and he has been unable to even successfully
handle a single one of these cases.
And the real mistake that Trump made was thinking
that Rudy could actually be his courtroom
lawyer when he is in way over his head.
A narcissist never makes the connection, though,
that, listen, Trump hired Rudy if Rudy is
the idiot and Rudy is making Trump look like
one as well.
Trump also must be the idiot for hiring Rudy
to begin with.
The way Trump and narcissist work is any good
is solely their own doing, but any bad is
solely the fault of others.
Period.
Full stop.
And to some degree, remember that Donald Trump
sent out Sean Spicer.
I want to say it was the first day of Trump's
administration.
Maybe it was the second, but I thought it
was.
Within hours of the inauguration, Trump sent
out Spicer, his first press secretary, to
lie about the size of Trump's inauguration
crowd size.
That made Trump look like an idiot.
And it's been four more years of the exact
same stuff.
So, yes, Rudy is making Trump look like a
fool.
But Trump hiring Rudy confirmed to us that
Trump was the fool before Rudy filed even
a single one of these completely bogus lawsuits.
Again today, a voter fraud hearing in Michigan
unclear as of this moment whether Rudy Giuliani
is participating, but would not be at all
surprised to see him there.
Let me know on Twitter, what do you think
is the point of these hearings?
What are they trying to get out of them?
Is it just raising money to pay off campaign
debt?
Is it something else?
I'm de Pakman on Twitter.
Let me
know
your thoughts.